when people say they're trading time for
money I told you I don't really like
that phrase because it's usually used
kind of condescending how you trick time
for money up so pedestrian but I think
actually most people can have a good job
and if you really get focused on it you
can earn a lot the challenge is that
even if you are working at a
nine-to-five job you still have to think
about building an asset because your job
could be taken away you could be fired
you could be laid off you could go on
disability or a global pandemic could
happen whatever the case suddenly that
entire single source of income could go
away so what do you do if you are
working at a nine-to-five job and you
want to build an asset an asset is
something that can produce income even
as you sleep an asset does not need the
same amount of work as as a nine-to-five
job an asset can be incredibly powerful
so what are some examples of assets of
course there's writing a book there's
building a program a video course all
that stuff but the most common asset in
the world is a portfolio investing in
the market so before I ever had a
business I was investing in the market I
built up a portfolio and that was my
asset and that asset has grown and I
believe that the vast majority of people
should start there as their primary
asset it's easy its low-cost it's
effectively as automated as you can
possibly hope for an asset to be okay
then I started my business and I started
creating lots of assets so programs a
book etc I didn't think of them like
that I was like I got to write this book
so people stop asking me about IRAs here
you go
but it turned out in retrospect this
book is an asset and even as we speak
people are buying it on Kindle and
physical books etc they're buying into
Indy bookstores are checking out the
library and my
we'll get a check and they will write me
a check every quarter or so that's an
asset I wrote emails that have generated
hundreds of thousands of dollars that's
an asset I wrote blog posts and even my
team worked on blog posts that bring in
people to our site that then turning to
customers that's an asset as well so you
can start to see wow there's a lot of
possibility around here to create an
asset an asset is taking what's in your
head maybe as a consultant or a
nine-to-five employee and packaging it
up documenting it and then making it
available for other people to access
incredibly simple on paper incredibly
profound because this asset doesn't
sleep this asset can be automatically
sold and used and that is how you can
start to really scale both your reach
and also your income with the
coronavirus with this crisis companies
are now looking into the entire sales
division and saying oh my goodness we
have all these salespeople
how could we outsource this how could we
have a remote sales team instead of a
sales team with a physical location how
can we sell our products or services
over the phone without a massive
overhead they're thinking differently so
if you have the ability to close phone
sales if you have the ability to close
products and services companies are
willing to pay you a hefty Commission
when you can demonstrate that quality we
can demonstrate that you have that skill
set closing will be one of the most high
demand professions in the world because
companies need revenue they need
salespeople they need skillful
salespeople and they need them more than
ever especially when things are coming
back to normal they need revenue and
they need closers what if someone out
there right now is watching and like for
me for example I feel like in my life my
career I'm right here but when I come
out of this I want to be up here how
does someone work on themselves during
this time work on changing their
identity for the positive how we go
about approaching something like that
great questioning so that's what we
should be doing right now there's
that's people that come out of this is
gonna be the ones that sort of sat
around watch Netflix all day and then
there's sweatpants which I did for the
first few days and then there's those of
us that decide I'm training I'm growing
I'm preparing to be a better verse to be
when I get out and one of the ways we do
that is by listening to podcasts maybe
like myself reading things right now
really growing us during this time
because as you said your identity it's
like a thorough style I'm in a room
right now on the temperature set on the
wall your identity is the thoughts
beliefs and concepts you hold to be true
about yourself this temperature in this
room is not based on external
temperature outside it's not the
external things in our life to bring us
bliss joy and abundance
it's our internal identity and it sets
the temperature of our life so if your
identity 70 degrees of money 70 degrees
of happiness that's what you're going to
get if you can alter that thermostat
setting it doesn't matter how cold it is
the outsider how warm it is outside that
regulates the temperature of your life
and actually your associations your
collaborations and the things you read
and listen to in your proximity so you
can change that thermostat setting while
you're working right now while you're
waiting to go back out when you get back
out there you'll have a different level
of abundance bliss happiness
relationships all of it alter that
thermostat setting through your what
you're reading listening to and who
you're hanging around talking to also
right now that might farmers Gump I was
around when crack first came out I've
been getting money since I was 15
you know and and then I was you know
that was the dream everybody wanted to
be you know paid a full I live day but
not to that extent and then I was able
to do what everyone else's dream was to
be a rap mogul I did that fashion mogul
did that you did nothing now I'm doing
television networks art galleries like
what would I do differently you know I
sold companies I got beautiful kids I'm
living good in the middle of a war and a
pandemic I'm moving like it ain't
nothing you understand something you
know I'm playing a different game you
know what I mean
like I don't want to fit into an
industry I take it and I like to do it
on my chance so I didn't fit in the
music business
I took the music business you know if we
could move when I was moving and when I
tired of it I said let me go do fashion
I didn't just come in the fashion
I made a dent and change the whole game
in fashion as far as robbery Rachel Roy
Charlotte Ronson and all the other
things and the doors that were open so
now even in art you know I did it all
that didn't years ago now my game is
television network game now how many
people you know have won at that game
probably nobody personally but I'm
trying to do that not many people can do
you know I don't like hustling on the
crowded block but it means I want to
play a bigger game but also you got to
do it real cool can't sell out to do it
and can't sell your friends to do it you
have to have integrity you got to do it
with style the classic exact you feel me
Ellen Claire you know a real general can
only lead in a war people pretend to be
generals when nothing is going on I'm
seeing a lot of fake generals sitting
around like soldiers but I'm a general
I'm I'm outside fighting right now I'm
outside putting out more work than
before and ever my numbers is up while
everyone is frozen networks can't even
move and make move make thing and I'm
doing it so I'm feeling real arrogant
about it right now because I've been
always saying though you independent you
could be prepared for anything a
recession I didn't even know it was
pandaboy pandemic poof everyone's
texting me about cash now here's the
thing got to be thinking about people
are where they are in their lives
because they listen to someone's advice
and someone giving their advice and you
take it and that's situation you have
two characters one is the influencer the
other is the influenced you listen to
the influencer who influenced you to go
do whatever you want to do for example
the influencer says cash is trash and
you say you know what cash is trash let
me go take all my cash and just put in a
real estate because that's I'm gonna be
a millionaire the influencer says you
know Real Estate's the American Dream
and you go by realistic cuz you think is
the American Dream the influencer says
you know never study politics because
it's a waste of time so you don't study
any of that stuff and then you look at
that philosophy and you see if it works
during good and bad times and if a
philosophy only works during good times
is not a worthy philosophy to study if
philosophy is only worthy during bad
times it's also not a good worthy
philosophy to study you need a
philosophy that's an evergreen
philosophy that can be tested in good
and bad times for example caches trash
what is the opposite of caches trash I
don't know a single person in America
today or in the world today that doesn't
wish to add more cache why because if
you had more cache you're not going to
be controlled by anywhere you're at your
job your boss the marketplace the
industry the three point to unemployment
applying for unemployment two weeks ago
six point six million this year that's
10 million people applying for
unemployment in the month of March of
record by six six hundred fifty nine
thousand was a prior one why are they
needing this kind of search because they
don't have cash real estate is the
American Dream is real estate really the
American Dream or is it a great
marketing job because the real American
Dream is equity entrepreneurship owning
yourself something owning a piece of
something where it's not just putting
all your money into a home average real
estate return three point two percent
long-term am I really going to become
wealthy to through that was that really
the right way to go maybe the American
Dream is entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship they never study
politics Plato once said those who say
never study politics will be fooled by
those who do meaning those who say it's
foolish to not study politics will be
governed by fools who do that means if
you don't study politics other people
that do study politics who are fools
will govern you and they'll make
decisions for you
do you want that to happen so maybe you
are to privately study politics maybe
don't publicize it but you go study
politics and see what is really going on
what is the motive behind these guys
would have the most of motive behind
these guys again the whole purpose of
today's message is the following
sometimes it requires a bad time to show
up for you and I to ask ourselves if our
philosophies work during good and bad
times sometimes during bad times you and
I have to ask ourselves who are the top
five people I listen to the most how are
their philosophies doing today
when the economy expands for a hundred
and twenty nine months in America you
know how easy it is to make money
very easy but when the economy isn't and
it drops 39% in a month
now which philosophies work because cash
is king today because entrepreneurship
today having a skill set is king today
knowing the politics and the motivation
behind politicians is king today because
you know no one can control you so write
down whoever the influencer it is that
influences you and write down their
philosophies and see if it's worked for
you good and bad times if it has keep
studying those people if it's not you
may need to make some adjustments to
which influencers you study to this
thing that we got going on right now
this what the media is calling the
crisis the epidemic pandemic the
greatest recession of all time which all
that by the way could be true don't
matter if it's true what matters is what
are you gonna do about it okay right now
you got a shift right now what are you
gonna do about it how you gonna take
advantage of it how does this become not
a crisis in your life not it not a point
to turn you down but a point to turns
you up you guys got to be positive right
now can't be can't be can't be negative
can't be going for every bit of gossip
and rumor that you're hearing so many
people running around looking for people
to go down it's unbelievable okay yeah
what is your prediction or fact of COBIT
on real estate okay so the question is
about real estate the effect of this
thing is going to be very damaging on
residential housing single-family homes
is probably gonna be net to have a
negative impact for probably the next 18
months to 24 months on office buildings
I think it'll have a negative impact on
apartments for the next three months
just because I'm a skeptical person and
then nine months from now Apartments
will swing and they'll be unbelievable
investments like if I if I was a young
person right now and I had money to
invest and I would start looking at
every apartment donated my market
knowing that by the end of the year I'm
gonna try to buy ideal I'm trying to buy
my first deal I would have my first deal
be at least 30 units try to get it up to
90 units and preferably get it over a
hundred units raise money but people
didn't be over a hundred units find
something in a great location pay a fair
price for it and it's gonna be such a
great investment over the next three to
five years to come the ugly if you want
more advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there
but when things get back to normal
you'll go out there and get a new job